hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I oh
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well so these are the
nine basic overarching motives that
Bentham thanks human beings have you
notice that already where we're beyond
the level of the mirror animal animals
do desire 12 preservation the physical
desire they want two things that they
like to eat so for instance dogs not
only like you dog food they also like to
cat food because cat food is sweeter
than dog food in general so I'm good for
them to eat it but they also like to eat
after use if they get it because it's
got salty sweet tastes good for that but
the end as I
or to animals what if sex animals one of
the other things that feel good a lot of
animals want to be liked by other
animals whereby by human beings the
designer candy is the animals don't
really worry about wealth you know I
asked those squirrels you know gathering
up their nuts are concerned about
sustaining themselves for the winter but
that's more instinctual that I think
they don't generally well they do desire
power don't because they there's like a
you know pecking order sometimes horses
are particularly prone to this sort of
thing Lions you know number one cause of
lion deaths of wild of the Lions is they
get into these contests with each other
but they don't worry much about the
reputation they don't worry about
antiquated the same way that human
beings do but that once the malevolence
don't really apply to them quite the
same way as wouldn't humans either so
let's think about about these Bentham
says these are the basic motivations
each one corresponds to particular pains
that we want to avoid or particular
pleasures that we want to have enjoy
let's run through these one more time
what is the nettles it's when I take
pleasure in somebody else's being
pleased so I do good things for them to
make them feel better take away pain
give them a pleasure and then I feel
good as a result you can also you know
be sympathizing with somebody feeling
pain because they feel pain I care about
their welfare well that one's is sort of
the exact diametric opposite i inflict
pain on somebody else when I take away
their pleasure that makes me feel
pleasure I see them having a good time
I feel sorry that's come on one's
physical desire what is that comprise
you know food sacks relaxation
intoxication massages if you're into
that sort of thing really anything you
know clothes that fit you nice I suppose
nice smells some people guy suppose
could be like a loner for few Maddox
yeah if you're like shaving I suppose it
be physical desire you know how many of
you guys actually enjoy shaving and it
did have a single one surprised you
don't all have beards that that's why I
have a beer because i don't like shaving
yeah it's a lot simpler or not to shave
self-preservation we have desires for
that right if i attack you your body
should actually put you into a defensive
posture why because you don't want to
die you actually want to stay alive
that's a good thing it includes fear of
pain of the senses lava bees desire to
continue to protect one's own life
designer for reputation I think that's
pretty straightforward enough you care
about how other people view you if they
have pleasure and thinking about you
that makes you feel good if they feel a
sense of pain discomfort in thinking
about you that makes you feel bad that
make sense what else desire for a midi
you like to be liked by other people
everybody does desire to be liked by
others you have others well disposed
towards one ready to help one out that's
a basic motive for human beings sorry
for wealth we just talked about that
that's something
it's pretty easy to relate to why do you
want well because you know you can buy
pleasure pleasant things with it and
there is a pleasure just in having money
desire for power he says this is also
called by the term ambition it includes
a designer for positions offices and
things that provide power so this is
probably a motive for many of you isn't
it you want to succeed you want to when
you get your first job you want to stay
in the entry-level position why not is
it just you want to make more money or
do you actually want to have you know
some so authority some some chance to
decide things to get to tell other
people what to do that's in the actual
human instant what about religion
Bentham says well as a distinct motive
we don't really need to worry about it
because it really just folds into the DS
for the most part you just kind of put
God into the picture so we're not going
to talk about that so much those are the
motives now how should we evaluate these
motives and gentlemen this is the ask
the question what is their general
tendency other motives that right off
the bat we considered and we can say
update then everyone's most people think
that's good don't they malevolence why
other people to be hurt so that you
enjoy that that's that seen as yeah
right what about desire for a while
glued bad just in between what do you
guys think let's say we take a vote
everybody asked to vote so by show of
hands who thinks that desire for wealth
is in general
mayotte today I have a single taker no
nobody thinks that is corrupting root of
all evil anything like that you do you
know I'm just good I think for all of
those on the right side of noise like
they could be bad but they can also be
good like yeah here it is ok so how
severe so they really want to make a
person feel like if they have if they
are desire than you know to be wealthy
to like the extent of like one hundred
percent like they're going to be I've
seen whereas like you're powerful you're
technically like you know the cookie gun
don't ya for but you're ruthless in your
garage Republic for swimming is fun you
know that makes sense Bentham doesn't
talk about it in that way but you're
kind of driving at something that he
would say like if you completely
dominated by desire for well you're not
going to motivate at all by benevolence
because you've got this one motor that
runs everything or by design for
friendship there are some people that
are so desperate to be liked that they
do a lot of dumb things you know what
would you get your hand up what were you
gonna say I just agree
I should work out well track that
assessment yeah now notice you guys are
bringing in other criteria to make to
make sense out of that are going a
little bit beyond utilitarians which is
okay we've got all the utilitarians I'm
not one myself so I'm pretty sympathetic
to those those ideas bathroom will say
things like desire for reputation amity
well they can be good or bad depending
on how they lead so I think you're right
if they if those were the one single
thing that you're focused on is probably
going to be a trainer however if they
add reputation you know you make even
self-preservation that's all you've ever
thought about you know in one way that
kind of stunted why'd you miss out on
some pleasures well you might also like
interpret every single thing rather than
to subtract that would be Dan to it then
people that are constantly on edge and
run into certain physical desires if
that's all that's going on in your life
it is you know I just want to eat all
the time just when I have sex all the
time just want to shoot up all the time
but also put in there that's sort of
like the definition of addiction and
that wouldn't be good either now Gunther
says well because these things depend on
circumstances we can't categorize them
automatically except perhaps to some
degree the Netherlands malevolence it
has automatically good death but even
but now even malevolence could be a good
thing like let's say you were really
angry that's part of malevolence you
were really angry with somebody who's a
very bad person in his do
very bad things and your children
because you're so angry with them and
there I say a whole bunch of other
people from harm or even death your
malevolence is a good thing that isn't
that overall from a utilitarian
perspective remember we take everybody's
letters and beans into account I mean I
wouldn't I personally I think a lot of
you would say no it's still a bad thing
killing somebody being motivated by
anger to kill them but he told during
perspective it's a good thing isn't it
like if you let's say you could go back
in time and get in a bar fight with
Hitler yeah that was the german beer
hall push they'll presumably use it well
I don't you was record probably done
there's kind of a t-tauri another this
fight let's say you know you go to the
bar get liquored up sir trading insults
back and forth you know dirty Nazi dirty
whatever you know they had a lot of
insults for everybody starts fighting
break a bottle slashing across the
throat you just probably save 12 million
people right you're a hero because your
malevolence are there ways in which
benevolence could go wrong do good to
everybody maybe you're doing good to
potential serial killer who's going to
go on you save their life and now
they're going to do terrible things to
other people yeah with your benevolence
is in the sense that like your fake
pleasure to someone that's also feeling
I your son what's wrong oh that's an
interesting idea so like for instance
you go around handing out free heroin
junkies because you know that use you
know
right right it will say you're in a free
needle program which is a good thing
right because we don't want that we
don't want all the junkies to get aids
and hepatitis and God knows what else is
going around and then you actually make
it by yourself I could increase exposure
this would be a very good thing if I not
only gave them the needles but I gave
them the smack it's pretty cheap for me
to get my hands on it I'll see you in
connection now give the police evidence
a bunch of stuff out here you know buddy
here you go here you go and it's not
good for them to be shooting up it is
very pleasurable this is a lot of
downsides overall so you're gonna get
your benevolence could in fact be a bad
thing from utilitarian perspective this
is a rather extreme example yeah it away
but it works so how else could we
classify these motors Bentham says
there's two ways one is in terms of
thinking whether they are social or a
social or anti-social so he talked about
social ones what are those those are
ones that are going to sort of put
people on the same page there in a
united people's interests or invitations
yeah what would it would be included
their benevolence definitely right but
what else you much but sending social
motives desire for reputation if you
care about what other people think of
you aren't you more inclined to act in
such a way as to promote their pleasure
and not provoke their pain so you're
probably going to be on more or less the
same page what else design from amity
works the same sort of way sending
social motive could it go wrong could it
could my desire to be friends with
certain people make me create pain for
people you know we go and start a
criminal enterprise start analyzing
things like that kind of high school and
stuff sure reputation could love for
reputation meteor do things that are bad
for the community is a little sure but
in general these actually lead to good
outcomes don't so good social outcomes
what about things like physical desire
self-preservation is there for a while
too sorry for power so long as they're
kept within certain boundaries right not
entirely dominating a person well those
are neither necessarily social are
necessarily antisocial they can put us
at odds if I want to be rich and you
want to be rich and she's the only
person in town that we can get rich from
we have this in the heat then your loss
is my gain in my games your loss is a
zero-sum game so we're not necessarily
on the same page but you know what if we
all work together I get wealthy together
foot in fact share motives the only
really antisocial bonus is going to be
loved us nothing thinks that we can
assess motives by saying that the reason
why malevolence is generally bad as it's
generally going to put us at odds with
each other it's generally going to lead
to worse outcomes or consequences in
terms of utility so whatever is made of
lead to greater utility if we were all
motivated by benevolence there was our
main idea if I want to make other people
happy other people want to make each
other happy wouldn't it be a nice place
overall right there a lot of things we
probably wouldn't do just think about
driving for a minute in driving we're
not usually motivated by desire
well physical desire i speeding is kind
of thrill but I think it fits in there
self-preservation people do dumb things
I think they're about to die sorry for
power I don't know I like asking people
you like casting people you get a kick
out of them do you like getting stuck
behind somebody who's driving slow under
the speed limit then that get out of
nerves and then some people like make a
game out of it like the tailgate the
other person and the person slows down
even more or they box each other and cut
each other off I think that's that's
desire for for power zire for friendship
you know we cut the other drivers back
nice let people in could these be good
or bad here into a four-way stop where
everybody wants to leave the other
person is that overall good or bad it's
good that they don't hit each other
right is there any aggravation involved
in that drives me nuts because I'm kind
of a rule you know I know the rules on
the road you should be going it makes me
angry producing painful maybe in some of
these circumstances different motives
have have different effects that's
probably enough about